bts's gin takes center stage in their
new music video plus its new music
Friday it's my favorite day of the week
here on the daily Denny
I'm Jenny director proud member of the
BTS army and I know we have been
chomping at the bit at some new tunes
from our back damn boys but the k-pop
groups epiphany comeback trailer dropped
on Thursday and this will hopefully hold
us over until their new album love
yourself answer is finally here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it gives me the feels y'all Jin takes
center stage in the clip which shows him
on a journey of self-love which is
something the group opened up to me
about when they were in town ahead of
the Billboard Music Awards has there
ever been a time where you guys did it
love yourself and how did you overcome
what pendopo and doing these things you
thought vehicle boy something actually
my final goal of the whole my whole life
is to love myself like for real because
you know it's always the hardest
we sometimes compare ourselves to others
and you know like sometimes get really
depressed or you know so but in love
like we should be we should be you know
take up the mask and be true to ours who
we are and I think all right sometimes I
read it read the text in online it says
that the best way to love yourself in
reality is like to grow ourselves like
you know it could be like a it could be
like exercising working out or it could
be from in the mines so like um you know
to watch ourselves like growing it's
like the best way to lower self they
also told me that the love yourself
trilogy is all about finding honesty and
love but also talking about the dark
sides of love listen I cannot wait for
the third album of the series and love
yourself answer drops on August 24th
ahead of their North American tour the
guys announced on Wednesday that their
final tour stop will be at New York City
field on October 6 which will also be
their first u.s. Stadium show now army I
know a lot of you are tweeting me hoping
to get beats yes to your home state but
listen you guys know they love being on
the road and seeing their fans so
they'll come back around I know it I in
the meantime it is new music Friday and
we need to talk about Tyler the Creator
because he is proven he is good at music
videos Tyler heads a military fleet and
CEO again feet reek a little cheese
I love that I wasn't a big Tyler fan
until I saw him at Coachella I have to
admit but when I saw him I was like okay
he slabs and I'm sold that check by the
ways off his album flower boy and things
are in full bloom for a choice of bond
his new album is right around the corner
and he unleashed one more taste of what
we can expect from it with his
affectionate new song animal
[Music]
ages
smooth jams right easy-listening choice
album bloom is expected honest 31st and
finally we've been gifted with another
new single from supergroup LSD which is
made up of labyrinth SIA and Diplo it's
called thunder clouds and all I want to
do is turn this up in the rain
[Music]
there you have it my new music Friday
picks for your hearing pleasure now it's
time to go enjoy the weekend but before
you guys go make sure you check out one
of my favorite eat eclipse of the week
Janel Parrish and Lana Condor talking
about breaking barriers in their new
Netflix movie to all the boys I've ever
left see you guys on Monday enjoy your
weekend